a blooded and bandaged poor lince in one
of English football's iconic images
having played on after this head injury
with the wound patched up
the captain acclaimed at the time as a
warrior for helping England reach the
1998 World Cup
prioritizing football over Health now
brings the realization for INS of the
risks we've seen so many players now
with hinders you know going down I just
think about when I played in Rome you
know I'm not banging my head and went
off for 10 minutes and I got back and
played on the pitch as far as I
concerned I could have had a concussion
in my time you know we never thought
about mental health or concussion or
dementia those type of those things you
know and we just got on with it how to
better protect player welfare has been
top of the agenda at a gathering of
football Chiefs but the global game is
split
during the meeting of football's
lawmakers here at Wembley the fa back
temporary concussion substitutes but the
faa's chief executive said they were
very strong and very different views in
the room and we didn't reach consensus
Mark bullingin believed allowing players
to be replaced to allow lengthier
treatment would prevent rapid decisions
on those potentially concussed playing
on as Robin Cook did for another 20
minutes for Leeds after a collision this
season in the Premier League it's why
the players union is so concerned that
only permanent not temporary additional
concussion substitutions are being
allowed it comes to a point when you've
got the leagues the unions the governing
bodies key organizations and groups like
The concussion Legacy Foundation who are
all United and calling for the same
thing
and yet the lawmakers are going against
that they seem to be holding back the
tide they seem to be able to step with
other sports internationally and so
we've got a real problem here
there is now a growing awareness among
players about long-term health risks
cases of Dementia in former players have
heightened concerns about the
degenerative brain damage that can be
caused by repeated collisions
but football will remain behind sports
like Rugby Union in not allowing
temporary concussion substitutions yet
in a move disappointing English football
Chiefs and brain injury experts Rob
Harris Sky News Wembley